anytime you're looking to achieve a goal
you need to look at the risk-reward
calculus I can certainly preserve any
archaeological site in the world if you
give me enough money i'll build fort
knox around it and make sure that no one
gets in but that's hardly a good
risk/reward calculus I'd be spending a
ridiculous amount of money for very
little preservation and no community
benefit in this particular case we were
able to spend very little money enhance
preservation and create an enormous
community benefit the site was called
Inca octa it's located about a hundred
miles east of Cochabamba Bolivia which
is the third largest city there so it's
truly in the middle of nowhere at an
altitude of about 10,000 feet I would
talk to the community time and time
again about not growing crops on the
site and not grazing cattle at the site
not playing soccer at the site and I was
not able to stop them out of desperation
I put up a gate five miles away from the
site in consultation with the local
community I said to the community if a
Bolivian comes through charge them
nothing but if a foreigner comes charged
them ten dollars and this is an area
where the per capita income was probably
a hundred dollars per year and they
looked at me like I was crazy that
nobody would pay ten dollars to look at
these rocks but I knew that a tourist
who had rented a guide and a taxi cab or
a car and had driven 200 miles would
certainly pay ten dollars I said I will
even pay for the gate it cost fifty
dollars we put the gate up in the first
week for tourists came so we collected
forty dollars the next week for more
came so we actually had a complete
return on investment in a week and a
half I wish I could do that with all of
the transactions in which I enter more
importantly the community began to look
at the asset differently they stopped
growing crops and paid people not to
grow crops so they stopped grazing and
using it it became not just an important
part of their past in history which they
knew but this site had relevance to
their daily lives not just in tangibly
but tangibly a real economic benefit as
a result i form the sustainable
preservation initiative to try to change
the paradigm of the white archaeologists
deal with can
munities and preserve their sites
traditionally it's been about repairing
walls and consolidating them and it's to
change the attitude to focus on people
and not stones